à toutes et à tous bienvenue donc dans
son caddie avec béatrice et vias bonjour
vous êtes chargé de mission dans le
cadre d'un accord entre la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de la martinique
et la chambre franco haïtienne de
commerce et d'industrie est-ce que vous
pouvez nous préciser justement quel est
votre rôle quel est précisément votre
mission béatrice ilias alors ma mission
déjà merci de m'accueillir martinique
ma mission est d'aider toutes les
personnes qui aimeraient investir ou
faire quelque chose avec haïti comme
vous le savez haïti est un pays un petit
peu à part donc tout ce que vous avez
vous comme règlement comme loi comme si
tout ce que vous connaissez vous devez
le laisser de côté
et voir haïti différemment bien
évidemment on a des règlements et des
lois on a des codes du travail on a tout
ça ne vous méprenez pas mais ce que je
veux vous dire c'est qu'en général il a
été vu au filet et fil des années il a
été prouvé que il vous faut quelqu'un
sur place pour vous aider quelqu'un qui
connaît le terrain je dois avouer que
j'ai 23 ans en haïti donc ça aide
effectivement j'ai travaillé dans le
secteur privé et dans le secteur public
donc effectivement j'ai des deux des
deux interfaces et en fait c'est si vous
voulez y ait plusieurs délégations à
venir en haïti accompagné par la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie de martinique
et effectivement ils ont réalisé que dès
que vous avez quelqu'un sur place c'est
mieux ça vous aide ça répond à vos
questions ça vous dit oui non peut-être
mais au moins vous perdez pas de temps
vous perdez pas d'argent vous savez où
vous allez et on peut faire plein de
choses ensemble très bien donc votre
mission est une mission de veille
économique mais également de conseil
d'accompagnement de celles ou ceux qui
souhaiteraient donc faire des
investissements en haïti tout à fait
donc veille économique comme vous l'avez
dit aider pour les appels d'offres être
là parce qu'il ya des choses sur le
terrain qu'on peut voir et ne pas voir
les appelle les manifestations appellent
l'intérêt et c est effectivement être le
lien donc faire un premier vous avez la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
martinique
qui fait un premier qui montrent un
premier dossier qui voit ce qui est
faisable pas faisable qui ensuite me le
transmet de et de là je fais
effectivement un autre nettoyage si je
peux dire pour voir effectivement dans
quelle mesure le projet est réalisable
ou non et ensuite à partir de là vous
avez des voyages de prospection et en
organise tout pour venir les chercher à
l'aéroport et faire de leur voyage un
succès alors vous avez enfin la chambre
de commerce de d'industrie de la
martinique et la chambre franco
haïtienne de commerce a organisé un
petit déjeuner pays c'est comme ça que
ça s'appelle
cette semaine c'était en fait avant-hier
donc sur ce thème faire des affaires en
haïti alors est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui marche ce que vous avez du
monde comment comment s'est déroulé
s'est passé ce petit déjeuner est ce que
vous en être sorti ça casse mais je dois
dire j'étais agréablement surprise quand
on voit que la ccm son slogan l'esprit
gagnant l oms l eau je dois dire
l'équipe du département international je
dois avouer qu'elles ont effectivement
l'esprit gagnant tout était très bien
organisé il ya eu un esprit très
convivial des gens ce ne n'était pas
inscrit sont venus quand même
j'étais en retard à mes premiers
rendez-vous malheureusement parce que
j'ai été attrapés dans tous les coins
avec beaucoup de questions donc c'est
vraiment très agréable
encore une fois on le voit haïti attire
les gens et les investisseurs est
également d'autres personnes qui veulent
éventuellement partager leurs savoirs et
leurs connaissances pour le support
technique la formation professionnelle
et c'est donc vraiment je dois avouer
que j'étais exhaustive vraiment
agréablement surpris béatrice il ya
c'est ce que ça peut se chiffrer à peu
près on sait que l'an dernier au moment
justement de la signature de cet accord
entre ccm et et chambre franco haïtienne
de commerce et d'industrie on parlait du
dizaine d'entreprises martiniquaise qui
semblait manifesté un intérêt pour haïti
un intérêt d'investissement est ce qu on
en est toujours là une dizaine est ce
que c'est davantage maintenant
assez d'avantagés j'ai eu des rangées
des journées marathon jusqu'à maintenant
dans quel s est davantage
oui j'ai plus des 30 rendez vous donc un
accord donc si c'est exponentiel depuis
ça depuis à peu près un an alors c'est
quand même surprenant voire même
paradoxal parce que en ce moment quand
on parle d'haïti
on ne parle pas d'un contexte a priori
favorable pour l'investissement alors
évidemment vous pensez bien que pense
que la reconstruction notamment à port
au prince est ici ou là dans le pays
après après le séisme est pas
complètement terminés et puis c'est
surtout une relative instabilité
politique tout de même y'a pas longtemps
le premier ministre a été changée et
puis il ya des manifestations depuis
quelques temps assez massive populaire
qui réclame avec insistance parfois le
départ de joël moïse le président de la
république
voilà qui est soupçonné on va dire
d'être plus ou moins lié au scandale
petro caribe voilà pour résumer la
situation alors en tout cas oui je vous
vois un peu oui oui mais faut bien y
venir je suis entièrement d'accord avec
vous s'est penché à te dit a priori qui
favorise investi chez vous dire je vais
je vais répondre par une simple phrase
que je dis tout le temps parce que la
politique comme on le dit toujours de
toute façon haïti est un pays résilient
et la politique en haïti se résume à 30
ans de démocratie 22 gouvernement je
vais pas parler du 23e parce qu'il n'a
pas été ratifiée donc on va pas le comté
donc ça résume tout je pense ça résume
la situation effectivement tout n'est
pas toujours rose on se lève le matin on
sait pas toujours si la journée va bien
se passer mais il faut savoir qu'à y
tient une position géographique non
négligeable à une heure et demie une
heure et demie des états unis on est
tout près du canal de panama et surtout
haïti a un statut de pma pays moins
avancés qui vous donne des avantages
qu'il faut considérer définitivement au
niveau fiscal et dégustatif aussi mais
surtout niveau fiscal et douanier
alors on va revenir sur les outils les
avantages qu'ils qui pourrait
effectivement
permettre de faire des bénéfices parce
que c'est ça en fait c'est du bidon on
parle de business là ça allait réussir
ça allait faire des haltes et leurs
opportunités d'affaires en haïti donc
faire des affaires mais tout de même sur
ce essayé d'éluder mais sur ce compte
est spolié
je veux dire qu'est ce que vous vous
qu'est-ce que vous justement chargé de
mission conseil a en quelque sorte dans
cette affaire quand certains vous disent
oui mais bon sur le plan politique moi
ça me préoccupe un peu ça m'incite pas
trop à y aller qu'est ce que vous
répondez pour gérer votre cahier
résilient et qu'effectivement ça fait
des années que ça dure
je pense pas que ça va changer
maintenant vous savez que vous avez une
mission de l'oim hier qui a dit que de
toute façon je n'ai le moïse rester en
place et devait commencer à gouverner
donc vous avez votre réponse je pense
effectivement c'est pas rose tous les
jours mon arrivée on travaille au
continuer à travailler et il ya plein
d'opportunités donc il faut les saisir
alors est ce qu'il y a omis à part ce
contexte politique est ce qu'il y à
d'autres difficultés qui pourraient se
présenter aux chefs d'entreprise
martiniquaise et martinique qui
souhaiterait donc intervenir en haïti je
dirais que si en fait c'est un petit peu
la raison de ma présence que si vous
n'avez pas quelqu'un sur place pour vous
aider vous pouvez effectivement il faut
pas comme je dis tout en rose ou pouvait
faire des mauvaises affaires il faut
quand même effectivement avoir qu'un
gain sur le terrain être bien entouré
pour saisir l'état d'esprit finalement
le fonctionnement d'haïti parce que pour
nous martiniquais et guadeloupéens ou
voir même du année il ya un avantage
c'est que on a des cultures très proche
on a le français et le créole qui
peuvent effectivement servir donc 2 de
moyenne communication donc donc voilà il
ya tout ça
donc mais voilà une fois qu'on a dit ça
est ce que on peut arriver là et puis se
dire oui comme je suis martiniquais bon
les haïtiens vont accepter facilement
manquez pas l'écrire c'est non voilà
c'est ce que pas forcément haïti n'ouvre
pas je vous disais que c'est important
d'avoir quelqu'un sur place qui voudra
vieille dollars ce que nous aurions
l'haïtien par principe est très
protecteur il va pas forcément ouvrir
ses portes une fois que les portes sont
ouvertes elles sont ouvertes et vous
seriez surpris de voir à quel point on
peut vous ouvrir les portes vraiment
c'est un accueil extraordinaire j'ai
jamais vu ça
oui je pense que nous avons
effectivement il faut quand même on peut
pas arriver en territoire conquis et se
dire je vais faire des affaires en haïti
non ça marche pas comme ça vous avez des
institutions très sérieuse pour vous
permettre d'investir de ci de là
effectivement de vous accompagner
mais quand même on fait pas ça comme ça
est ce qu'il ya une notion de deux
karibéa unité commune entre antillo
guyanais et haïtiens ou est ce que des
femmes et des hommes d'affaires qui
arrive en haïti en venant de la
martinique sont considérés comme aussi
comme quelque part des français quoi des
français qui viennent et donc voilà
au delà de non vous ne direz pas
français non blain ah oui
vous n'êtes pas ici est donc vous êtes
blanc c'est comme ça que c'est un peu
perçu et voilà la compagnie alors quels
seraient les avantages des points
positifs qui donc vraiment déterminerait
du dynamisme et dans cette relation
économique et commerciale entre
martinique et haïti
vous avez des domaines n'oubliez pas que
vous avez un code des investissements
qui a été établi en 2002 qui vous
permette justement d'avoir des avantages
douaniers et fiscaux et c'est dans ce
sens qu'il faut vraiment je pense
définitivement tiré parti de vouloir
faire des affaires investir en haïti et
on a sélectionné avec la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie martinique on a
sélectionné des secteurs porteurs qui
pourrait intéresser qui ont d'ailleurs
déjà intéressés des hommes d'affaires et
des femmes d'affaires de martinique dans
plusieurs domaines et il faut savoir que
à mes yeux je le dis et je le répète
haïti est une terre d'opportunités
qu'ils gaspillent et c'est vraiment
dommage et ans c'est en ce sens qu'il
faut vraiment vraiment continuer à
pousser tout cela béatrice ilias pour
donc conclure conclure neutrons entre
entretien s'cusez moi vous êtes chargé
de mission dans entre pour l'accord
entre la cci à mai la chambre franco
haïtienne de commerce et d'industrie
pour investir en haïti alors justement
que peu rapidement en résumé que peut
apporter à haïti à la martinique et
inversement quoi voilà sur quoi ça peut
se jouer
ces échanges ont été je dirais qu'à et
il représente une terre d'opportunités
pour la martinique et la martinique qui
peut apporter énormément de son savoir
haïti savoir ce clash support technique
aidant inversement donc haïti pour pour
la martinique que terre d'opportunités
oui mais en quoi qu'est ce que je veux
dire qu'elle inspire quel secteur quel
est le secteur porteur par exemple vous
allez vous avez l'agriculture l'énergie
la construction et donc l'information
professionnelle mais ça ce sera la
martinique vers haïti la martinique vers
haïti merci merci béatrice hignard
d'avoir répondu donc à nos questions
autour de cette thématique donc des
opportunités d'affaires en haïti bonne
journée à vous tous vous retrouver yves